and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review though
oh yeah this is the greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life
alright the guide of spoilers this is
gun named Thor and he lives in the giant
pipe organ and this is the magical world
of Asgard I had a nice guard once it
didn't work and they're under attack by
these evil monsters for the ice giants
core sort of like if you cross the orcs
with mr. freeze Austin uh freeze up baby
but when Odin nectar comes along it
destroys them on ice giants toughen the
nipples the old connector is like oh
you'll be king if you don't act like an
idiot don't worry dad I'm turning you
into a human and sending you to have so
you can hang with the other idiots but
meanwhile Odin's other son is like I'm
not really your Sunday night no I'm one
of those ice monsters all right yes we
need you tell me in case my first time
was a cold-hearted idiot I wanted a
backup an idiot yeah crap so Odin goes
into a deep Odin sleep which is kinda
weird that's just a leak go into a coma
so the ice master son takes over is king
and so he tells the leader of the ice
monsters will suspiciously like Ivan
who's to assassinate Odin ooh heavy
still dying asleep you die in his sleep
of death meanwhile apartment is like
help you okay by stealing your shit
so Thor goes and it kicks the crap out
of all these shield agents who seem to
have forgotten that they carry guns but
one of them is like use that weapon over
there that looks like a mix between a
bow and arrow machine gun
holy crap that looks awesome so Thor
comes to get his hammer the guy a mystic
has gun but fans Laurie can't get the
hammer what the hell I'm depressed he's
depressed call off the kick-ass gun oh
so Natalie Portman is friends trying to
get Thor out so they have to use oh
they're cunny to get him out of that
security he's crazy
okay free so forum floors friends try to
go and save him but that is he
brother since the most diabolical thing
he can think of a recycled version of
gourds but then solar goes up to the
monster and says let my friends go take
me to the movie but let floors hammer
flies over to Thoren bring em back
tonight because Odin said he who grabs
the hammer and has the spirit of Thor
would have the power of Thor okay it's
more the Hammers going to the hand I
read their hand picking up the hammer
infusing three and now he has to go back
to the giant pipe organ to stop his
brother and the evil brother discusses
his evil scheme I am going to destroy
all of the ice giants now wait a minute
I thought they'd with the big guys they
are then why am i stopping you because
every life is sacred destroys his evil
brother
today's the even ice monsters who are
probably really pissed off and will kill
them later but it turns out he has to
destroy the Rainbow Bridge in order to
make that happen
no now we do never travel two worlds and
see my girlfriend again wait you guys
build it right yeah can't you just build
another one there's also one other scene
after the end credits yeah like every
scene after the credits of a Marvel
movie I can sum it up in three words
time I'm so through with a night of fun
they're really action-packed then we
only have one question
wait does natalie portman turn into this
one now that'd be a good Avengers
character this is just insane for the
Hulk
I mean Charlie Sheen